[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
happy thursday it's a few days before
all-star weekend
and you tapped in with your favorite big
three
welcome to the group chat presented by
fanduel live in the bleach report out my
name is cabbie richards
our betting expert is kelly stewart
who moves the market like jj watts
signing in arizona
and our little baby
faced assassin is greg ivory where are
you right now cause i don't see the
you know the baby face uh picture behind
you
okay cabbie cat cabbie i'm in the a man
i'm in the a
uh i'm i'm here i'm here for the open
run
saturday uh that white boat
guys i can't hear anything all i hear is
you guys shane all right here are you
guys talking
they're gonna be here on the two on two
game and i'm gonna be there covering
them man really
all i do is hear you all i'm hearing is
you
really all right so okay so yeah
we're gonna we're gonna tell you guys a
little bit more about open run uh later
but it's the 70th all-star weekend in
three days in atlanta where g-money is
currently
and every day there's a new opportunity
to hit a long shot uh let's start with
the slam dunk contest these
three young talents have the opportunity
to announce their arrival
on a big stage we're talking about ob
topping anthony simons
and cassius stanley let's take a look at
what they've been doing this season
score the knicks goes up and topping it
up on slack
and stanley has his setting i mean these
two
obie toppings
[Applause]
oh
the odds are dropping on fanduel tonight
so let's take a look at the contenders
oh by the way happy 23rd birthday obi
topping
so let's take a look at our our
contenders obitable from the new york
knicks
cassius stanley of the uh indiana pacers
currently in the g
league with the fort wayne mad ants and
anthony simons
out there in portland uh g-money any
early favorites in the comments
cabbie uh let me introduce the new
people to the show this is called the
handy dandy ipad and this is how you get
your hoodies
let me look in here and see if i see
anything actually you know what
i need you guys to get in the comments
and let me know which young player is
going to make his mark
in this year's slam dunk contest let me
know in the comments it can be a gift it
can be in text
it can be anything get creative let me
know kelly
did you do any research on this one
ah i like that cabbie's laughing because
he remembers
i was sitting in the green room last
year at the br
stage i worked so hard i bet on my dude
aaron gordon
i was about to cash that ticket and then
it just got yanked away from me so of
course this year i didn't do any
homework why would i do any homework
if it's all up to the judges that just
get to be a little biased
uh i'm going to go with a favor here in
obi toppin
and cabbie can stop laughing about all
of my losing tickets wait so wait
is is there a particular judge that you
that uh has
as has your ire from last year
you know if i ever get the opportunity
to go to atlanta where greg's at maybe
i'll have greg do it for me you meet
d-wade this week and greg
could you remind him that he owes your
girl 1100 bucks
hey we need some we need some present uh
gifts in the comments for ob top and
congrat
happy 23rd birthday once again i like
cassius stanley the young
like a six foot six guard from from duke
he has a 44 inch vertical
which was measured at the 2020 um nba um
uh uh the combine excuse me i'm so sorry
and like and yeah i haven't been able to
see oh uh
cassie stanley played that much in
indianapolis
he's been with the g-league team but i
do have access to youtube and this kid
can fly he's got all kinds of bounce he
doesn't really rely on lobbying the ball
for his dunks so maybe that'd be more
impressive kelly mentioned aaron gordon
who can just
who's just one of the greatest dunkers
ever maybe cassie stanley goes in his
bag
and unleashes some of those i look
forward to seeing that 44-inch burt
on on sunday so cassie stanley is who
i'm locking in
for the slam dunk champion uh g-money is
um
who does everyone in the comments think
has got this cabbie it's it's literally
all over the place i see
everybody every contestant name in the
comments
uh let's start off with one h g l
e e k topping for the dunk contest he's
rocking with
kelly and topping uh wade 08 21
uh he says simon he's rocking with
simon's and he gave us the gift for this
guy's concert
gift right there the simon's gift i like
it i love it
mgo blue is filling the comments up with
cassius cabbie he's rocking with
you and your pick uh
i'm just gonna make this call cabbie i'm
gonna make this call we got kelly going
with topping
you're going with cashes i gotta go with
my guys
i gotta go oh you're gonna go with my
guys simon
he's shooting look listen here listen
here out of high school he was highly
recruited
he did not go to college went straight
to the nba from high school
uh he's he's a very very
very talented young young kid uh he's
shooting 40
from three he's not only a shooter
that's
people might think he's only a shooter
he's a sleeper
in this in this contest for a reason
take the plus money
put it on him he's in practice with dame
every day cabbie
he's in practice with david that's legit
you know dang's out there teaching them
the ropes
so put it on my guy simons man
last year a lefty derek jones jr won so
maybe simon's getting a little bit of
love from the judges as well josh smith
is one of the judges and he's a lefty
also okay so let's talk about the
three-point
shootout steph curry is officially the
old guy in the club
at 32 years old the nba's greatest
shooter
is competing against five other scorers
that can give you 30 points
on any given night and if you need a
reminder about their range
well here you go
[Applause]
mitchell how many game winners does
booker have so far
[Applause]
steph give me that shimmy give me that
shimmy
wardell stephen curry
he needs another title uh so the odds uh
come out on fanduel tonight so make sure
you tap in with uh fanduel a little bit
later on
but let's take a look at the contender
shall we devin booker who won in 2018
jaylen brown and jayson tatum both new
to the contest
steph curry has participated five times
zach levine low key
shooter my guy's shooting about 44 from
three-point len and donovan mitchell
who is just spider-mitchell who just got
ranged for days
so um g-money as you are the resident
bay area native
but right now in the a is the army
following your lead
with steph curry or are they taking the
field
i would hope they're following my league
i mean we're talking about
steph curry here one of the best
shooters
ever to play the game uh i mean kathy
he's leading the league right now and
total point scored for a reason i mean
he knocked downs a bunch of threes
come on now so uh i would hope they're
following my lead but seriously
i need you guys to get in the comments
give me gifts
give me uh pics give me whatever get
creative
in the comments let me know who you are
riding with for this three-point contest
kelly now you didn't do any research for
the slam dunk contest
did you do any research for the
three-point contest
i spent some time looking at it i
narrowed it down to three guys
donovan mitchell zach levine devin
booker if this was
let's call it three weeks ago a month
ago i probably would have went with
donovan mitchell but my dude is ice cold
right now
and i understand he's not gonna have
anybody playing defense against him
but i kind of wonder if that's in his
head a little bit as gabby mentioned
it's hard to bet against zach levine
right now he looks
like the guy to bet you already know if
he looks like the guy to bet
i'm not backing him i'm taking the young
dude in devon booker
the phoenix suns up and coming in the
west this team has been superseding
expectations
all year long after they had that early
exit in the bubble
i i love this phoenix suns team i want
devin booker to win the three-point
contest
i'm going with the hometown dude loki
like jaylen brown or me not low-key but
jaylen brown went to high school in
marietta
georgia he might have some family in
attendance he has basically he has like
no
pressure on his shoulders he's not steph
curry who's leading the league in
total points and three-pointers made
it's jaylen brown he's got a real nice
stroke
and you know i we don't know what the
odds are yet
from fanduel but i imagine he's his odds
are probably some of the longer
um odds so i'm going with jaylen brown
uh to win the three-point contest cause
you know a lot of times we just bet on
the favorites they don't come through
last year buddy healed one the year
before that it was joe harris
and the year before that was devin devin
booker so like the big name guys don't
always perform the best
in the three-point shootout so i'm going
jaylen brown g-money um
was your audience taking steph curry or
are they taking the field
gabby i saw a lot of steph i saw a lot
of step
takes in the comments but i'ma spread
though off i'ma spread the wolf here
i got david c 1503 he's rocking with
zach levine
zach levine uh i got wade wade against
rocket with curry
uh james james can lawn james canelon
he's rocking with jason tatum jason
tatum
uh we got d book joe yen uh
i just want to make it make it known
everybody that i said you're walking
away with a hoodie by the way every
every name that i just call you're
walking away with a hoodie uh cabbie
nate savitz is rocking with steph
and uh shout out to him man he's rocking
with steph and
and i already said it i already said it
i gave out enough hoodies
i already said it i'm rocking with steph
for a reason um
so yeah let's ride man we go ride with
steph curry
all-star weekend coverage begins on
sunday at 6
30 p.m eastern on tnt so make sure you
check it out every week in our
chuck versus america segment uh we take
on the most lovable person
in sports media who is charles barkley
and whenever he bets against us
we promptly hand him an l last week we
trusted the process
uh and we cashed in the three by two
take a look
one seed right now in the east the 76ers
let's go jojo outside and beat squad
danny green alone in the corner
that took literally a minute and 15
seconds to hit the first two possessions
of the game
were three-pointers g-money is that it
was like
the easiest like in the history of our
show
cabbie it was very joyous we had a real
good time with the vibes on the br
bedding instagram live it was an easy
one this was a real
easy one uh we need some more like these
gabby we need some more easy ones
i love the easy winner man i love an
easy winner kelly you know about those
easy winners
yeah no sweat we call them rocking chair
winners where you just get to sit back
take it easy that's what the 3x2 is even
though our producer
jake likes to call them a two bite
that's perfect let's take a look at the
updated standings
you know what when um chuck chuck is
getting wise to the game cause when he
rides with us
his fortunes change we're comfortably
10-1
chuck is at six and five so a four-win
lead
equals four hoodies right greg ivory
why not i'm in the comments got the
handy dandy right here i got
motive eight ed you're walking away with
a hoodie for your devin booker gift
i got ben son k619 he's rocking with you
and jaylen brown cabbie
you're walking away with the hoodie i
got
courteous outlaw hurt outlaw
shouts out to you for your comment
brother you are walking away with a
hoodie
young pittsburgh is in the comments
young pittsburgh is in the comments
he's rocking uh with america he's
rocking what america he said chuck does
not have it he's rocking with us in
america
cabbie that's four i can keep going but
i'ma just no no no that's good that's
good that's good
four wins four hoodies it's beautiful so
for tonight's chuck versus america
the tennis back let's hit it quick and
get rich shall we
earlier today we asked you on twitter
which team will be the first to score 10
points
the miami heat or the new orleans
pelicans
this is a really tight race verified are
one of the closest we've had
america is leaning with the new orleans
pelicans
with 52 of the vote greg you need to
check in with the squad
yes cabbie i definitely need to check in
with the squad on this one this one is
very very close gang squad
i need you guys to let me know in the
comments
which way are we leaning are we leaning
towards the heat
or are we leaning towards the pelicans
to score 10 points first let me know
we're going to be riding this on uh br's
betty's instagram live too as well
later on kelly
did you uh do you do any research on
this one
[Laughter]
greg is getting on my nerves he knows
i'm mad he's in atlanta i'm stuck in
vegas
he's just poking the bear don't you have
like something to be like at magic city
like a reservation get some lemon pepper
wings i feel like you have something
better to be doing
anyway i uh look kathy and i do this
little thing on thursday nights
called the nba betstream presented by
fanduel
and i learned last thursday night you
should never be laying
the chalk on these this is such a coin
flip the first to ten even bad teams i
think cabbie laid like minus 160 with
the jazz or something crazy
i did and guess what it lost i am not
doing that i'm not making the same
mistake as cabbie
on these again a coin flip i'm thinking
the heat minus 106. it makes way more
sense to me
this pelicans team has showed some
promise lately yeah this heat team i
know they're without a couple of
all-star players
but i think that's a little over
exaggerated at this point in time i'll
take the heat
race to 10. hey the the pelicans almost
overcame a 19-point deficit to chicago
yesterday and um uh
brandon ingram and lonzo ball got
benched in the fourth quarter
so i think those two guys they might be
pissed or whatever
so i feel like they're gonna come out on
fire so i'm going with new orleans
because
those and zion has just been amazing
it's a nice send-off going into all-star
weekend where
he's gonna play for the first time so
pelicans in the last five games they've
they've reached the tenney three times
so i'm locking in the pelicans
versus miami to get the first team to to
ten points
uh g-moneys are are the commenters
leaning with the twitter poll which is
52 on new orleans
gabby the commenters are back and forth
they're back and forth steve
jobless is rocking with jimmy butler in
the miami heat
shout out to you guys with the hoodie uh
that's the least we could do for steve
jobs benson k619 and he already got a
hoodie but he's rocking with the
pelicans
uh i have jack jack
jack j blue uh it looks like he
is rocking with the miami heat he's
rocking with the heat cavity you see
they're back and forth the next one
i'm gonna just i'ma just decide i'm
gonna just decide here we go we got
uh we have jake jt
jkt is riding with zion and the pelicans
therefore i am riding with zion in the
pelicans
but before we move on cabbie before we
move on actually everybody i said you're
walking away with a hoodie
i need the comments to do something for
me i need them to do something for me
can i get scientists detectives
students gifts in the comments because
uh
they they like to do research they do
research and uh
those are some of some of the people
that like who research so can i get
those in the comments just
just to get the vibes going just a
little bit just to get the vibes going a
little bit
we need some microscopes we need some
telescopes
we need like a magnifying glass yeah
anything science related in
all types of things related to research
calculators
all that uh check out america check out
uh
the iconic inside the nba the pre-game
show
to see if chuck is riding with us in new
orleans
or if he's out on his own or actually
riding with kelly and the miami heat
um tonight the pelican versus heat game
is a rematch
of a christmas at matinee game when
duncan robinson dropped
seven threes he was absolutely flames um
and and we're asking you about the
hottest bet in america the br betting
3x2
will there be two three-pointers made in
the first three minutes
of the game new orleans and miami greg
how confident
is the audience and how comfortable are
you that the three by two hits tonight
every week cabbie you know what i'm
writing i'm writing the yes
every week everybody in the comments uh
just say yes you know we are riding
they're filling the comments up with uh
research
actually let me give away some hoodies
right now uh mjm
1122 you're walking away with a hoodie
uh m go blue
you're welcome over hoodie it's a bunch
of research going on in the comments if
you guys do not know
moving on so that leads to you kelly
that leads to me
asking you one more time did you do any
research on this one kelly did you do
any research on the two by three
i know you've been riding with us are
you still riding
listen greg i know that you don't listen
to me
ever and anything that i have to say so
i'm gonna say this
for one more show fanduel is giving out
free money
if you do not bet the yes you are
costing yourself money
stop overthinking it the answer is yes
all right you know what i'm
i like to listen to kelly's advice
because it's put many uh
dollars in my pocket so i'm saying yes
usually it's
lonzo ball or brandon ingram that get it
started from deep from new orleans
i know they're they probably have a
little bit of a chip on their shoulder
today so
that's money and then duncan robinson on
the other side
a three-pointer in the first three
minutes if that happens
we are cashing another one and improving
to 11 and one so
i'm saying yes tonight the there's a
there's going to be two three-pointers
made
in the first three minutes of the
pelican and heat game uh where's the
audience edgy money
gabby you know they're all over the yes
they are all over it mikey locks is in
the comments shout out to my guy mikey
lots he says the three bites lego
don't miss the three by two do not ever
miss i
i agree you know we're hot with the
three by two oh x8
baller oxa baller it says yes he's
writing with a yes
a handy dandy ipad he says yes also you
are a goat i think he's talking to you
and kelly cabbie i think he's talking to
you and kelly you guys are two goats
uh i got me mitch norris got the medea
gift right here if you guys can't see it
there it is
it says hail to the yes hey
i got one more cabbie one more uh
look at fortnite fan fortnite fan going
with the home alone gift home alone gift
yes i dig it up to you guys everybody i
said you're walking away with a hoodie
cabbie we are riding with the yes
if if if big meech is riding with the
yes
i'm also riding with the s nobody says
no to big meech or larry hoover
um make sure you get on fanduel to to
bet the three by two that's the only
place you can get it
in the world so salute to fanduel okay
so
saturday bleacher report is pitting
quavo
and jack harlow head-to-head in a
two-on-two game
versus two chains and little baby this
is gonna be
legit i can't wait for this take a look
at the promo
grit determination anger i'm a
basketball guy
you're gonna have a long day i think i
got some tricks up my sleeve
expose somebody i think all of us do
have basketball games
don't let me heat up man that's fine
there's gonna be some trash talking
going on
i'm about to take over this whole ship
man or we're gonna win call it a
guarantee
it's impossible to see two chains
without saying two chains
i can't wait uh now okay there are
unfortunately fanduel doesn't have any
odds for this this two on two uh
match-up in open run so we just baits
them up
so let's look at the let's take a look
at the odds that we made up the
overwhelming favorites
are cuevo and jack harlow mine line
minus 215
five and a half point spread two chains
a little baby
plus 180 on the money line plus five and
a half on the point here's the best one
all right those are those are great but
who will score the first basket quavo
plus 200
2 chainz 225 jack harlow 300
little baby 400 i think little baby is
the shortest by the way
um so that's what uh that's what g money
is gonna be covering tonight uh excuse
me on saturday
out there in atlanta so greg you're on
site
uh you've spoken to the players do you
have a scoop for your army let us know
my g
cabbie i got the scoop got the scoop got
to talk to the guys last week
had good conversations quavo said he's
coming out firing
he's not playing he's coming out firing
from the get-go
my guy to chain said he's the go to this
he's the goat
he said call him tom brady he is the
goat he ain't worried about
nothing that nobody's talking jack
harlow
he's ready man he's ready he he was
basically he said he's going a little
baby a little bit little baby said
he wouldn't go let jack harlow do this
do that so it's going to be a little
little competition with them too and i
can see cueva and 2 chainz putting on
the show
they was talking about it and cuevos
said something about a lambo cabbie
he said something about putting a lambo
on it so we're going to see man we're
going to see
kelly kelly
i'm not even going to say it this time
give us your take who are you riding
with where are you leaning
let me tell you this greg besides two
chains i don't even know if i could name
a song from any of these guys and that's
just
the honest to god truth catch me on that
note 2 000
chronic uh but it but in all honesty
this is the most comical thing ever
these are not odds by fanduel that means
one of our producers
set this 35 cent line
this is not an odds maker this is the
funniest thing ever give me the plus 180
because first of all
these lines are absolute utter trash yes
i
set it two chains and little baby plus
180.
even if they lose that is incredible
value because why
our producer doesn't know how to set the
line well that okay well kel's let's
i'm i'm on the other side so we should
we should side bet we should put a
little hunted on her or something
and then and then whoever wins greg we
can greg ivory can bring us back some
lemon pepper wings
but i'm going with cuevo and jack harlow
cueva
is an actual hooper he won the nba
all-star celebrity game a few years ago
jack harlow's hooping with tyler hero in
his music video
he's friends with donovan mitchell from
his time in the in the bill
and he's only he he also has his own
team like his
his crew of boys they also hoops so
quavo and jack harlow to me is a lock
like i don't have a lamborghini to put
on it i have a remote control car that
i'm probably going to put on it and that
hundred if you want a side bed kels
but yeah that's who i'm riding with
g-money who is who is the army rider
with quavo
and jack harlow or a little baby in two
chains
cabbie i see a lot of two chains in the
comments
meech is back meech is back and jack
jack and meech uh they rock it with two
chains right there as you guys can see
ben ben uh ben o-n-k 6-1-9's rocking
with two chains
richie 21 rocco with my guy quavo
rocking with my guy quavo hold on let me
get it uh oh there it is
you guys can see it right there rocket
with my guy quavo uh
wade's rocking with cuevo fortnite
rocking with cuevo
cabbie it's apparent now it's apparent
i'm seeing it
they're rocking with the amiibo migos
and cuevo jack harlow
uh and the boys and i don't blame them i
do not blame them in fact
i'm betting my guy adam lefkow i gotta
bet with him
uh we're gonna put a thousand on this uh
adam
are you is it crypto or is it cash
hey ho cold hard cash
adam lefko man we go put that bet on the
line you guys are gonna see the
see see the results on saturday um but
looking forward to it
uh quavo jack harlow y'all gotta turn me
up man let's go
so make sure you get on on the br app on
saturday at 8 p.m eastern to check out
open run
our homie greg ivory is in the a he's
gonna give you a behind-the-scenes look
all kinds of access on bleacher report
and the bleach report instagram channel
so
check out g-money so thank you so much
for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned here today
you can't watch a game live without
sprinkling a little bit on it so
you gotta do that fanduel has all your
all-star
weekend wagers and odds later tonight so
tap in with fanduel
and open run streams on saturday at 8 pm
eastern once again on beliefs report
alongside kelly stewart and greg
yes sir guess what get out of here i
gotta get one more person in the hoodie
i faded i
shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie i just had to show the
fans love
i had to send them off with some vibe
i'm sorry go ahead wait speaking of one
more i need to have a side bet here with
cabbie but we're taking out mikey
locks's egregious line
let's just call it two to one i want two
chains and little baby
two to one for a hundred bucks that they
win deal that means if i win you owe me
200
that means if i lose i only owe you 100
bucks you know i have 39 bucks in my
venmo account i'll i'll find a way to
get the 160 the other 161 if i lose the
bet
done deal alongside kelly stewart and
greg aubry my name is caviar richards we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
you